hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
ru garbage the show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and fun if they
grew up classy or if they're complete
trash I'm your host H Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day here at mommy's
house in Bluebell Pennsylvania where the
beers are cold and the pools empty my
co-host back in New York City probably
making a grab at some empanadas to load
up on before he heads back down to the
Jersey Shore he's the brains behind the
operation he's my best friend let me
tell you something folks next time you
reach it for a best pal make it a kippie
as kids all right give it up for Kevin
James Ryan everybody hey gang happy to
be here thanks for tuning in as always
make sure you rate review subscribe on
iTunes and full video available on
YouTube you can subscribe there as well
they're for everybody waiting for me in
North Wildwood I'll be back later today
yep the Sam's Pizza ready daddy's dumb
at home
keep the [ __ ] funnel cake hot the
kids coming back and I like it gang we
are ecstatic to have our very special
guests here on the podcast today we're
gonna go over this rap sheet this man
has got on him as an actor he has
appeared in beer League Grand Theft Auto
a little help Aqua Teen Hunger Force
girls Californication Louie inside Amy
Schumer trainwreck red oaks and of
course Crank Yankers he is the host of
everybody is awful on barstool sports he
has also appeared on the Last Call with
Carson Daly tough crowd with Colin Quinn
Chelsea Lately the Howard Stern Show
Jimmy Kimmel Live Gotham comedy live the
Joe Rogan experience
the Church of what's happening now and
of course a hundred and twenty eight
episodes of that metal show so we know
he's got a little bit of cash
everybody's mind today is he garbage
ladies and gentlemen give it the [ __ ] up
for one of the oh geez mr. jim
Florentine ladies and gentlemen thank
you my biggest creditor all of them you
it wasn't listed on there I played the
Bluebell firehouse when you mention
Bluebell I'm like I remember being there
Pennsylvania 45 minutes outside of
Philly I member bringing a hot date
there too I go look I got this gig
tonight like I'll go with you and I
didn't want to tell I was playing in the
firehouse that's always not free toner
was the Bellagio it's this thing I'm
doing you know for my friend favor no
I'll go with you I got nothing to do oh
my God look at this firehouse she's like
all right and she didn't fit in there
stripping yeah holy [ __ ] oh that's funny
man thanks for doing the show yeah no
problem and I've spent a lot of time
down a while what did the comedy club
down there so I spent a lot of summers
down there yeah that closed down how was
that I never I never even got in there
that closed before I started but I
remember looking around at it it was
amazing they did two shows a night seven
nights a week see you next time you know
so is the grace great for me to do to
just getting up and do SATs it's better
when I first started you know then the
nightlife there used to be open till
5:00 in the morning the clubs in
Wildwood they get on today while one
plays it fast and [ __ ] loose even
nowadays did I know it was open the five
anymore nowhere else was open the five
in the morning she would do wild plays
by its own [ __ ] rules I was I've been
down I've quarantined so my parents have
a house down there when she hit the fan
in New York and nobody knew what was
going on I'm like I'm getting the [ __ ]
out of here so me and my wife went down
there and we were hanging out and I mean
like just weekend after weekend there'd
be more and more people games on the
boardwalk open and not me and while
people are [ __ ] collapsed and all
over the [ __ ] world a lot while I was
doing the
ring-toss on Lori's beard it was crazy
yeah good time now Jim you were born in
Brooklyn but raised in Jersey did you
did you guys look like two years old I
moved from Brooklyn I remember being an
act pretty much grew up in Jersey I live
down in Florida for a little while but
pretty much Jersey born and bred as a
kid you live down in Florida when I was
in high school junior senior year I
moved out I my family moved down there
and a couple years later I want blue
back again so I spent about four years
down in law did you move back so long as
you went back with your family the day I
graduated from high school I drove my
shitty car back from Florida New
Jersey's I hated it so bad down there
yeah you know I hidden and I came back
my yeah my parents decided to move
between sophomore and junior year which
was horrible because you know you have
no friends yeah both grew up with a
notice when you're down in I got putting
like this private Catholic school where
you know they were all like rich kids
and stuff and I was like you know this
heavy metal dude with you know Ozzie
written on my notebook I've got a long
hair they were all driving daddy's
Mercedes I had beat-up shitty Volkswagen
your parents decided to move you down
there though my dad wanted to open up
like a catering business down there you
know he's in a dream he had a good job
in New York and in Philadelphia he
worked for a while and he just decided
he wanted to buddies like lunch
structions and go to construction sites
and you know and buy a whole round of
them like six or then a completely bar
that was my dad's dream too he wanted he
wanted he always wanted a hotdog stand
and he wanted to lay one of the lunch
truck because he's been fascinated with
them our entire lives yeah we bought a
router like six lunch trucks you know
boy write off these people but I just
feel like completely tanked that just
didn't work out the Roach coach his baby
gotta love them oh no they're really all
that shitty and they rose dude a hot dog
from one of them things was [ __ ] a
okay man they cooked him in something
else on those cards man oh yeah I know I
used to but that was his dream he wanted
to do that for some reason I don't know
what it is with dads in that from the
Northeast for some reason they think
Florida
it's like [ __ ] you know like it's
just the end allbe it go down the
Florida that's all they all want to do
is go to [ __ ] Florida I don't get it
well his mom and his brother live down
and we go down there like once or twice
a year for vacation okay yeah we had a
lot of family down there you know so he
just decided to take a chance it didn't
work out I love the ball deck I love the
balls for leaving a good job you know we
had seven kids so you know you had to
feed a lot of mouths so leaving a good
job in New York City to try that you
know try that out just didn't work out
for what did he do in the city he was a
count for a Dun & Bradstreet okay you
know grow up middle-class yeah yeah
we're going to seven of us you know
crazy seven god damn the Irish Catholics
they don't pull out I know the same my
mom's one of nine and it's like we're
like [ __ ] dicks dude everywhere we go
they meet cause it's ridiculous I know I
got 14 nieces and nephew all they marry
and I'm 33 no I just got mad but it's
like New York 33 we don't have kids you
know what I mean and they're like we
don't like I had five kids by the time I
was your age on my yeah it's not
happening over here it slow it down yeah
yeah yeah they started in like 20 21
they married the first person and that
was it yeah it's [ __ ] crazy seven
kids so did you guys grow up in a
single-family home would you guys have
your own place because there was like an
apartment or anything no we had a house
nice yeah so yeah we play yeah classic
you know white picket fence basketball
court in the back you know playing bass
warlords
my dad was you know the coach manager
all that stuff you know it was always do
day they always came to the game so it's
nice you know close-knit community it
was cool the neighborhood we all just
get together and just you know wreck
[ __ ] all the kids
we're wider than reckon [ __ ] there
that's the vasa kid finding something
you can [ __ ] break in the woods or
something cuz [ __ ] second-to-none
dude yeah just the kicks think kick
things off since you brought it there do
you guys have a garage growing up yeah
inside that garage did you have an extra
refrigerator like an old beat-up
refrigerator what so doesn't [ __ ] like
that we never had that we never had a
second refrigerator no garage fridge no
yeah I'm surprised you figured we might
have had one like in the laundry room
where the laundry was possibly a second
one okay I can't remember though we
always use that laundry room the top of
the washer and dryer we put a sheet over
top of that for parties yeah that's
where the bar would be oh that's a good
idea okay okay I ran late night sitting
on that thing later sweet vermouth and
cherries all over what the garage bridge
is like an indicator of like trashy of
link you know middle-class family
because they get they can't come to
terms with throwing out a refrigerator
so they just keep it somewhere else in
their house you know what I mean to them
it's this huge purchase so they put it
in the basement the laundry room the
garage so it's like a signifier of a
level of trashiness and I grew up with
one of the garage from like nineteen you
know it was from like 1964 so yeah yeah
I don't know I mean if they did have a
second what it was because you know they
we couldn't fit the food and then one
rip it's stretched out at you and your
brothers and sisters pretty close in age
is a 12-year difference between seven of
us
oh my mom was popping him out like every
year and then it was like every other
year towards the end and took a couple
years off at the last one we were pretty
close was that rotation trying to use
the [ __ ] bathroom down there that
must have been insane yeah you know it's
like well I always say because I didn't
masturbate for I was 21 and I said I
shared a room woman through my other
brothers so there's notes I could never
zdenda bathrooms you out to get in get
out so I just didn't have any personal
place to do it
oh you would have caught me in the woods
or something there's no way I could last
until 21 I mean I was looking at dirty
magazines in the woods like you know a
little for you know we built it yeah it
was [ __ ] little stash everybody had
that oh yeah yeah we go to garage sales
again if like a dime old playboys or go
to the woods and keep in our for you
know now
we get fireworks and Bob you know
blockbusters m-80s and [ __ ] like that so
yeah see that's the funny thing is one
of the reasons why we wanted to have the
honors cuz Kevin's old a bit younger
than me I'm 44 so he's a 90s kid I'm an
80s kid and technically you would be a
70s kid yeah pretty much even the
difference between those things it's
like in the eighties you know when I was
a kid wouldn't find Playboy's at a yard
suddenly [ __ ] right there yeah I was
definitely 70 [ __ ] a lot of
fireworks and I don't know about the 80s
but in the 70s is the ton of fireworks
selling fireworks at a yeah yeah we got
him for I don't know where we got him
from but we were always setting them off
well you know Maties blockbusters
blowing up people's mailboxes yeah what
a generation was really like your
generation was like the ones that lost
the finger fell off the high dive
[ __ ] crack their head open at the
roller rink so all that stuff started
going away we used to bring fire throw
me at concerts like a pack of
firecrackers and stuff that was a big
thing back in fact one of my brother's
well your older brothers would take me
is it people like no fireworks at shows
and just throwing him in the crowd she's
gonna close like like an inside square
garden yeah just a pack of firecrackers
just wing it and just you know be right
by someone's head they look around like
who did that and you just you know
pretend you didn't do it that's great
that was when you can't even like take
your shirt off anymore at a concert like
it back then it was just yeah if you
ever like looked at it like a sporting
game like a sporting event just
everybody's like smoking cigs inside
[ __ ] long hair shirts off fighters
were smoking yeah and then also they
used to always pass a joint around like
the joint was always passed along and
you just take a hit off you didn't know
who started passing but I was like the
thing to do or what was in it was like a
pay a forward thing everybody just
you've got a joint pass around to
everybody in your aisle wherever you
were sitting at a show so I was getting
high like 12 14 years old going to
concerts
what concerts are you going to I saw it
Lena Black Sabbath van Halen
Aerosmith Ted Nugent I had all the
brothers that would take me my parents a
guy you could take him just take care of
him again
they were like four or five years old it
was great yeah they know this would go
tell mom like I'm not gonna tell her I'm
smoking weed you go girl reader exactly
damn that's [ __ ] that's at 17 at 17 I
was like I don't like this I don't like
the feeling tired I'd smoke maybe three
times since mm-hmm I was the same day I
started like 14 or 15 we stole it from
like someone's mom or something you know
and got a high in the woods I had a
panic attack it 13 years old when you
don't know what a panic attack is you
really freaked now I'm like I'll I'm
panicking but when you think the feds
are after you when you're 13 smoking a
three-foot bong [ __ ] gets a little dicey
it does well those concerts must have
been crazy because that was that mean
that was [ __ ] lawless you're just er
there's no scan you're just ripping a
ticket that would they sneak you in and
[ __ ] like that and like make you hide in
the trunk and all that crap oh you could
get in at any age my dad used to take me
to pro wrestling matches at Madison
Square Garden and you had a few I think
either 14 or 16 to get in I think it was
16 because it was blood usually at those
matches yeah and yet so I I used to wear
my mom's high-heeled shoes like the kiss
platform screws and we're like long
jeans so you couldn't see so I looked
taller so I can get in cuz my dad's like
look I'm not gonna go from Jersey take
the train to Madison Square Garden you
can't get in mm-hmm so I was like I
would say let's just make you make you
look tall over some wreaths and it
worked I never got stopped I was 14
going I supposed to be 16 he'd give you
a briefcase to look professional on him
don't [ __ ] this up for me kid I know
because I'm gonna have to get the Train
away already got the tickets and a lot
stopped so I respect that old wrestling
stuff like in the 70s they have it on
like youtuber to WWE there was hardly
any kids at those shows is all like
grown men don't know wrestling now it's
the opposite that's [ __ ] awesome
let's go into the Florentine knives now
your dad was a fan of wrestling he or he
took he did Oh
so wasn't he wasn't taking you he's like
I'm going you can come with me oh yeah
you were jamming up his night probably
yeah if I couldn't get
got any bottles left me at Penn Station
all right let's go into the Florentine
house growing up growing up obviously
the bathroom was probably a chaotic
situation do you remember what kind of
soap your mom would get you obviously it
was probably a bar do you remember what
it was if I had to guess it was probably
cheap the cheapest soap because my dad
had you know seven kids so he'd probably
get it at like no frills was a brand
back then remember that yeah it's not a
real thing
yeah it was a real thing that's called
no frills come on that's garbage they
would sell like paper towels paper
plates probably so I remember there was
one aisle in the store like a half an
aisle it was just no-frills [ __ ] so so
I'm gonna stop he would get it would be
in the no frills aisle so it was
definitely cheap so I don't think it was
ivory because ivory was like the top and
a line that that was the Cadillac what
do you use now do you use like gel or
did you do you step it up a little bit
now that you know you're older and got a
little bit of cash you still go no
frills no you know I used to always take
them from the hotels and use I always
take them like I'm taking of taking and
using home thinking the hairdryer in the
roads and [ __ ] yeah take the iron you
know come back I took the soap and
there's shampoos and conditions for
years
yeah but now I probably just yeah
probably better I don't know what soap
it is I got it uh I don't know but it's
not shitty so yeah this is good yeah my
friends actually got a Bowtique so I get
her soap there it's probably some
organic [ __ ] but I just do it to support
her there you go little boutique action
now I'm antsy do you think you're
garbage or no what would you say yeah I
know I I'm you know I've been a fan for
you for years listen all your like you
know all your stuff so I definitely know
you're you know you're definitely a
little rough around the edges when it
comes to light partying and girls and
stuff like that but I don't know if
you're garbage pretty what garbage means
yeah it depends
well those thrills isn't a good start I
can tell you that yes stealing the
stillness shampoo from
and motel 6 that was nothing I mean you
know is it garbage when we are out
tailgating and we have just one drunk
friend that gets so drunk he doesn't
know where he is half the time and we
kissed him what in a cop him we gave it
to him as a beer and he drank and is
that I mean that is that garbage because
a good time whatever it is that is a
good [ __ ] time you make that face I
like this and then just kept talking
what is it said import it was 90 degrees
out so he's like I did just gave me a
warm beer you know he wasn't but that
was lazy made he wasn't sure and then he
just kept talking about 30 seconds later
I love how a muscle
Arina get that to a friend you still
talk to that guy
yeah dude as fun as the 80s and 90s were
like growing up in the suburbs the 70s
must have been [ __ ] awesome I didn't
remember you know as a kid I grew up
like I had this neighborhood all of us
were friends we had a baseball field
like we had a pool community pool and it
was a baseball field there we had the
woods in our backyard we got home from
school at 3 o'clock I think maybe we did
a homework for a half-hour and then our
parents to go okay be back home at 6
o'clock for dinner that was it and you
were gone for two and a half hours every
day playing football in someone's
backyard we had the baseball field we
get a game together there or we just go
in the woods and just you know I can
just mess around yeah look at magazines
let off fireworks or just hang out yeah
snow was just like beastly almost 6
o'clock and that was it so that was
pretty you know was great we're all
pretty much friends all the kids in the
neighborhood we'd all get together yeah
our little cliques and all that stuff so
yeah always pretty much what we did a
community pools not there anymore right
yeah it's still there yeah Wow yeah yes
and I would be open you know Memorial
Day to Labor Day or whatever so we go
down there and you know we'd always try
to get there lifeguard wet we jump off
the diving board and do a cannonball I
try to get him wet sitting up there
that's all we did the whole day he's
like you guys are [ __ ]
you know do you jump right by like it
almost like a you know right underneath
them jump way out there again I'm gonna
cannonball and your friend goes yeah you
got him wet they would just be mad at
whatever just being dicks and now did
you that I had my swim club we did it I
thought it was normal but the more we do
this show no one knows what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about we used to think the pool
people used to grease a watermelon and
throw it in and then you would have to
like try to get it to the other end of
the pool there was like teams do you
guys do that at all oh yeah apparently
my how much just a bunch of [ __ ]
hillbillies like did you ever go away to
like day camp or sleepaway camp or
anything like that no now Cam's yeah
that was always like rich kid [ __ ] I
felt like I mean my mom and I would
never go to a sleepaway camp that's
crazy yet I always heard a lot of the
rich kids the parents didn't want to be
around in the summer
so what would you do most summers just
play baseball in the backyard basketball
whatever you know baseball went front
till like the middle of July and then
that played football for a little while
too so that started like August 1st well
we're just hang out you know just hang
out and you know play stickball I was a
big thing we play were kids
I was [ __ ] great all right let's lock
into some questions here Kippy you want
to kick it off
I gotcha um-hmm have you ever snuck onto
a golf course to go sledding no ok ok
we're stuck in a golf course to do
something more [ __ ] up no I was never
at night no I'm not you know I've never
been golfing like two times before I'm a
lefty they never had club I didn't want
to buy clubs and I want to get up at 6
o'clock in the morning they go [ __ ]
golf when I'm on the roads a lot of
comedians would do that yeah a lot of
people I never really got into it so but
no I never it's not gonna do I've never
really around golf courses we did that
in Philly my dad took us and I'm like
might it be really common if I was a kid
I remember hopping a fence with my dad I
think it's like deep break into the
course I'm thinking any time you have to
hop a fence and like with you know your
father or parental figure it's never a
good sign you're doing something wrong
so you went sleigh riding on the golf
course
yeah like at night we would break in
like he we would like sneak onto the
course and he would be like throwing
kids over the fence so we can like go
you know end up ruining the fairway or
whatever Weiss
all right let's get back into the house
here growing up what chart what brand of
chocolate milk would your mom get you
know chocolate milk no chocolate milk in
the house at all was your mom hardcore
no my dad just you know there was too
many of us they would be gone in two
seconds so he wouldn't buy it because it
was just you know we'd fight over it and
you know he's just like I gotta feed
seven kids I can't afford chocolate milk
your dad was the one that went to the
grocery store that's the picture I'm
getting oh yeah and he would drag us to
go with off you know - he'd pick two or
three of us and he'd go to like four or
five different stores because he always
had coupons I'm like dad you're driving
you're driving 15 more miles to go save
50 cents isn't it I can't even figure it
out as a kid he loved the bargain
we had a Cadillac what he loved to eat
save 50 cents on eggs that's awesome
what uh what grocery store do you go to
now that's a big one there's like a wag
men's near my house
Nancy Wegmans foods I used to go to in
the beginning but I'll really go to
anymore but you're pretty much like wait
there's also like this local Italian
place near my house which is great they
got the best rolls the best meats a lot
of times so I go to support them you
know how to local businesses that's
great you you live in a single-family
home now or is it a condo single family
home so do you have a garage fridge now
no but I have one in my basement it just
just look here yeah second fridge just
for drinks and yeah there's only beer
yeah and I have another little like
monster energy refrigerator I got from
the company but I only have water and
like you know sparkling water drinks in
there for kids like my son is friends
well that's awesome
yeah but the refrigerators just be your
downstairs I don't care about having any
beer and refrigerator upstairs yeah do
you want is your basement finished yeah
do you have like sorry go was it
finished when you bought the house or
did you remodel that's the only reason I
bought the house it was a finished
basement with a more
with a baller that's okay I don't give a
[ __ ] about anything else I don't care if
it is the 1970s toilet paper man yeah
that's a big that's a big middle-class
suburban dream is to have that finished
basement with the bar that's like every
guy's dream oh yeah yeah every one of my
friends has it so yeah yeah do you have
any games yet like a ping-pong table or
a pool table bumper pool or the the top
of the line is a shuffleboard if you can
get your hands on a shuffleboard which
yeah shuffleboard but where would you
put the shuffleboard Oh people have them
in their basements if they have like a
big basement they have like yeah like
that like the ones at the bar do you
slide the metal discs on all right okay
yeah no I I have that like pop-a-shot
that's pretty losing a lot I got it in
the garage Mike my son at his friend's
the blast nice
that's pretty legit and I gotta tell you
as a little kid you you'd come across it
every once in a while but from your
son's perspective his friends if I
walked into somebody's house and they
had like like you're like you're saying
like the the Red Bull cooler or whatever
or something like that that's you like
what the [ __ ] does your dad do that you
used to blow you away when you'd see
something like that yeah they loved it
you know cuz they they you could go in
there they got drinks and then I over
liked it you know a cabinet where
there's all stacks and they're so
they'll go down there they just hang out
down there and open them up and get
their drinks I just say stay away from
the booze they know that you know they
young anyway but the Papa Schadt thing
is only like 300 bucks I thought it was
gonna be like 3 grand 3 on a box I'll
get it
yeah oh that's so trashy that's my body
had one growing up we would spend
[ __ ] hours in the basement doing that
hours yeah you know he's got that it's
good morning friends come over and stuff
but yeah it's good that one refrigerator
you separate the booze you put the water
in a one uh-huh you know to sparkling
grape drinks whatever the [ __ ] that is
you put them in there too with the
waters and you know the other
refrigerators all beer just liquor yeah
that's the American dream man yeah it is
what kind of snacks do you hook up for
the little guy
now you know they got chips popcorn
pretzels oh yeah
you get him any gogurts or any
Lunchables or anything like that he
doesn't none of that [ __ ] yeah now eats
regular stuff you know what I just found
and I fact you know I used to eat this
as a kid I don't know if it was I
remember in the 70s my dad would always
get his his tree tavern frozen pizza I
don't have that he always a frozen piece
of your bike and I've least eat it as
kids and it was amazing right and I just
saw it I was in a quick check the other
day getting [ __ ] I saw it in there like
well I haven't seen this [ __ ] thing
in 25 years and now my kid loves it
so I go to quick check to get shriek
tavern pizza and he loves it now
what the [ __ ] a quick check it's like
a wah wah
okay convenience store yeah yeah that's
a good media store yeah I thought it was
a check cashing place oh my dad thinks
that sells this okay how's the pizza you
know yeah they got the North American
distribution rights the quick check
mostly yeah nothing's better than a good
frozen pizza man you get your hands on a
good frozen pizza I'm uh it's it's
bougie to me we grew up a tombstone but
now I get in the French bread Stouffer's
French bread is [ __ ] clean living le
o's pizza was another one was family le
o's pizza in a couple episodes of
Hogan's Heroes [ __ ] good night
we were so trashy I think we called it
Elios for the longest time illios le oh
I think it's as I got older I'm like we
were saying it wrong for [ __ ] 15
years so your dad would hook you up with
that he'd get you Leo's pizza would he
get you like what was the ice cream
situation there would it be able to
bring that [ __ ] in the house or would it
be ravaged he would like Friday was
pizza night so you could you know get
the pizza on Friday that was the thing
no sometimes you get it from a pizza
place but other times we just you have
le oh so we were happy with that the ice
definitely wasn't Breyers if there was
Breyers cuz I was like the top brand at
the time if that was his ice cream you
couldn't touch it
for an old on of dads so we get them
more there whatever a generic not the
number and otherwise which is fine it's
a kid I don't give a [ __ ] yeah we would
get the the big the one in the big clear
tub like member was always like it was
like a four gallon er now when you sit
in our freezer for [ __ ] most of the
summer what there's a lot of any no real
good stuff expensive stuff has always
had a dad's he note on it that you
couldn't touch it yeah don't touch yeah
my dad was a sherbert guy and I was not
touching that as a little kid I was a
giggle [ __ ] yeah give me the
chocolate of vanilla swirl buddy you
keep that fruit [ __ ] to yourself you
don't like Sherby you're not a Sherby
guy it's alright but as a kid you read
what's rather ice cream yeah I thought
it was like French or something I'm like
get the [ __ ] out of my house what's this
Russian get this commie okay all right I
got one who's anyone in your family
everyone a Dodge Neon probably not
I used to have a Toyota Tercel oh oh I
used to get beer from a guy who drove a
Toyota Tercel it's probably Florentine
oh yeah I ran a guy I sold it to
somebody after it had like a hundred and
ninety-three thousand yeah I still got
like a grand for the car damn was it the
hatchback one no no it was the four-door
mm-hm it was a 1993 I bet when I started
doing was don't common a couple years
and I got a college agent somehow yeah
and I made like six grand in in like a
couple of months doing colleges like 750
bucks apiece toured over like old I
never had that much money ever I took
that money and I put it down on a brand
new car so I said I'm gonna beat all
these gigs so I bought a Tercel was like
9,000 I put six thousand down on nine
thousand dollar car paid the rest off
whatever and just ran out and bought a
brand new Toyota Tercel and drove over
for Robby like seven years
damn it was amazing and never broke down
once and needed tires every thirty forty
thousand miles but
well change was an amazing car yeah
those cars were so the American car
industry got [ __ ] crucified they
hated it I really wanted to buy American
you know my friend who buy a Ford ago
I'd like to buy a Ford what are you
gonna pick me up on the side of the road
and caddy 3:00 in the morning
dude I had I had a chef my first one was
a 95 Chevy lumina I think like an old
like grandfather car you know dude and
that thing broke down every there was
something wrong with it every two days
every two days it was like ah 300 bucks
here 250 there 20 there yeah I would
have kill firts or so yeah I Foley what
do you got I want to stay in the car
with him um did you ever or do you now
have a radar detector in your car I used
to definitely I have one for a little
while but it was still annoying it would
go off all the time yeah yeah they
didn't work yeah I maybe had it for like
six months I tried it I don't really
speed that much you know so I was like
what do I need this thing for it it
would constantly go off and just didn't
wash it out of me so staying in the car
as well did you ever have a CB radio no
okay
did you ever own an iroc-z a Trans Am or
a z28 no I was never a car guy I'm
always been like even now I got a Honda
Accord I'm like just I was never big in
the cars and flashy [ __ ] am I gonna meet
that stuff like I'm trying to impress I
don't know to me I was in some of my
family members they loved the car cars
and she felt like that may I'm just like
I just want satellite radio and and and
uh and cruise control I tell my sister
and air conditioned she goes well that
comes with every car oh that's all I
want and you see how she had a car but
do you use cruise control now you still
use cruise yeah yeah always especially
on the highway if it's 65 I'll set it
for like 72 what I won't get pulled over
so I just keep it at 72 or even I'm
driving through a 40 mile an hour zone
I'll put it out like 43 44 and just use
gurus control on the regular street see
I'm always worried that like I'll forget
that I'm driving it's like your foots
you know your foots just chillin there
well don't you see a car in front again
you know you guys I still pay attention
he's not he's not
sharpness tool yeah no I do cruise
controls great cuz then you just set it
where you know hard I'm not gonna get a
speeding ticket mm-hmm you know I'm not
gonna be I'm not gonna set it at 90 in a
55 but I know I can get away with 65 and
a 55 there you go
I don't think I've ever used it um have
you ever put bumper stickers on your car
oh yeah yeah I'm hauling what first
couple of cars mostly like Black Sabbath
Ozzy Osbourne Judas Priest Motorhead I
never put anything on after that and
then I realized this is immature
yeah yeah you're doing it as an adult
it's that I already got Black Sabbath
cranking from my stereo system with the
windows open we're a super loud system
so I've already can hear do I really
need a bumper sticker - did you do you
have a Center sound system in your car
in a like an upgraded system oh but I
did that's the first thing you did when
you were an amazing sound system I think
the sound system I did my first car
costs $300 a sound system was appraised
spend I spend more on that yeah that's a
real garbage thing dude I didn't say I
think I spent like seven hundred bucks
to put a CD player in my in my [ __ ]
Chevy lumina it was like this bigger I'm
gonna take the whole dash out it didn't
go back on it was a mess yeah
Toyota sticker an automatic I can't more
if you said that it was a stick it was a
stick man that's [ __ ] kids don't know
how to drive stick anymore yeah in a
state you know I looked at it like this
okay I could drive a stick and I'm gonna
be doing mostly highway mileage you know
driving these gigs and then also we got
better gas mileage to us yeah yeah yeah
I never even learned never learned to
drive stick I've a laid once i valeted
one summer and they like taught me in
the parking like I like get it from
where was into the parking spot but you
a stick car would come in like once
every you know ten weeks never happened
what jobs did you have growing up as a
kid Gym dishwasher busboy and
landscaping yeah three of the big ones
one how old were you when you started
working 14 yeah well that's a big thing
on the show it's like what you learn as
a 14 year old what you have like when
you're working with like real man
like ex-cons are like people getting
back on their feet the [ __ ] you learn as
a 14 year old washing dishes you can't
learn anywhere else
yeah I was a busboy and dishes and yeah
I pretty much I've been working I may be
taking three the coronavirus is the
longest I've got four since I was 14
years old I always had two three then I
worked in a hardware store you know I
worked in the garden shop and I would
make deliveries like lawnmowers and
stuff like that so I did that for a
while well yeah I was always about 14 is
when I started nice do you currently own
any Omaha Steaks no never happent good
never had him No classy okay has anyone
in your family ever been in the
contraption known as a money booth where
you stand in the telephone booth and
grab the money that blows around I'd say
probably not okay
they made my mom do it at the car
dealership the one time I was
embarrassed to say the least
[ __ ] grown woman reaching for one
dollar bills that well her her monthly
payment have you ever gotten a haircut
outside hmm it's usually not by a
licensed professional oh yeah I used to
I used to go to my friend's house his
wife would cut my hair I was trying to
think that we ever did outside but I've
done it in a kitchen before yeah that's
classy growing up did who cut your hair
when you guys are kids they think you
the barber did your mom or dad do it no
we took took us to a barber okay yeah
have you ever had your picture taken one
of those old-timey photos no I hate that
[ __ ] worse or worst I've got I'm
being with girlfriends and I want to do
that yeah yeah because then you guys
break up and then you're the [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the picture with the new guy
that's banging really who the [ __ ] is
this yeah I know yeah look like I faked
tommy gun and a stupid [ __ ] hat on
get out of here do you currently own a
drone no dear I have you ever owned a
paintball gun
now a t-shirt gun no what's he doing a
halftime at the Knicks we never went
paintball I never did that before I mean
the t-shirt gun I figured he prank he
could have picked one up over the years
yeah I could say that have you ever sold
anything in a flea market no but I go to
flea I would go to flea market and buy
stuff yeah there's a flea market near my
house and me and my friends would go
there every Saturday and Sunday one of
the days and just walk around and buy
used albums or get sneakers there
whatever so we'd always that was not
like that I and I bring my kid there the
same one I used to go to you know just
buy buy you [ __ ] yeah I think it's the
unknown - cuz you're like we would get
like I knew you'll get like a
pocketknife or like somebody would have
fireworks or so I was like [ __ ] you
shouldn't be buying you could get it a
kid in the flea market finds last last
year I got a mall to see this way market
let them off my air yeah I know we had
to ask for the good stuff
it'll be like some Asian lady yeah and
they'd be in the back in the car they
would not in the van yeah we uh we used
to get you sneakers there - Oh like they
would sell you sneakers they were you
know they weren't that worn and wood but
we get him for like 15 bucks a pair we
could be like 40 and we buy that that's
great did you ever gonna rest it when
you were a kid never not once
well pretty sweet pretty nice do you uh
did you ever wear a t-shirt in the pool
I would say yeah as a kid yeah no okay
we go swimming all the time now I never
did that
you weren't chubby as a kid where you
would chubby kinder skin I look super
skinny yeah you're in good shape you
silky is still in good shape why just
yeah I guess there was enough food to go
around
you have the bougie ice cream I remember
I weighed 87 pounds when I was in
seventh break those on the wrestling
team Jesus
yeah so yeah 87 my son just like 87 yeah
John Kim all right have you ever had the
Oscar Mayer cheese dogs with the cheese
already in them come on
wow it's got a bougie man Oscar Mayer
baloney yeah you have to rip the ends
off you can never eat the ends I know
that was that was definitely cancerous
that rubber [ __ ] that was all your was
you weren't a liverwurst guy where are
you Wow no not live work but that
Bologna was nasty what I [ __ ] love
right now I liked them when I when I was
a kid I remember trying it like probably
like 15 years ago you know what I had
the other day it's pretty [ __ ] good I
bought a bag of the hormones pre sliced
pepperoni and was just happen those they
were [ __ ] I haven't done that a
decade that's clean living right there
Hormel was real shifty man that was
right up there with Dinty Moore beef
stew do you remember that Jim no I don't
remember
Oh den team or beef stew was like
[ __ ] roadkill meat it was terrible I
was a chunky man you guys we got still
our mommy yeah we always got salami that
was happy too when it came on that roll
like he would roll like I came in like a
long like a foot long thing yeah yeah it
was a tough look in the in the cafeteria
because you knew there was three kids in
the cafeteria that I'd [ __ ] salami on
their lunch and you could pinpoint him
out like they were google map watch them
whenever you burp bad hangs with you for
a couple days just a burp and then burp
burping to people you know my friend's
face is like oh my god that's too
[ __ ] funny
that's good all right let's see here
have any of your home's ever had green
carpeting yeah I'm trying to remember
yes there was green stuff yeah yeah so
it's like a weird vibe
sorry go yeah there was green somewhere
are definitely mm-hmm if you still have
green carpeting it's definitely time to
update if anybody still has if you just
looked at the like [ __ ] do you currently
still use spray on deodorant yes you do
you're using spray what do you got right
card um no it's some I don't know some
like organic [ __ ] okay that's all
whatever like that I used to break out
like if I used that regular shitty
deodorant I don't know I know he's
worried I'd be sweating like a maniac
and I would I always had sweat but I
always had big pit stains and I was a
kid which is the worst oh that's bad
never wanted to be in class with big pit
stains I used to put toilet paper under
my armpits and dry it up yeah piece of
toilet paper sticking out when I'm in
class well that [ __ ] never was I finally
found like or dispray that works are you
better then I will use the roll-on like
that Tom stuff I try to that work for a
little while
it's C I don't think any of that organic
[ __ ] works good I want I want [ __ ]
flex seal you need the aluminum it's the
aluminum that stops it so all like the
organic [ __ ] doesn't have the aluminum
but some of them you can get it'll
[ __ ] likes it when cauterizes the
[ __ ] there was no there's no better
smell than men in speed stick oh so good
it was i beep it now like I just ran a
marathon in a [ __ ] in a desert within
10 minutes with that on but it smelled
amazing I know I had like a little bit
of hand of like medicinal smell to it
you know and yeah and girls loved it too
that smell but it's just like you know
no girls coming near me when were you a
co are you a cologne guy never- war for
a little bit I don't believe in cologne
do you remember what you wore it's
overrated do you remember what you wore
when you weren't for a little bit a
brute brute as a [ __ ] man's cologne
buddy I know twice Old Spice Old Spice
did you pop wear Cologne yeah he wore
cologne
what did he go for probably probably
- I think that's why he would have
rigidly discovered it in his bathroom
yeah that's old-school my stepdads a
Stetson man still Hey Dude every bottle
comes with [ __ ] spurs on those things
yeah I just stopped with the perfect I
don't know what the Cologne I don't know
I don't even like a good when a girl
wears a lot of perfume [ __ ] turns me
off yeah you like tasting it and [ __ ]
it's all it's all over your hands yeah
that's gross goin up did your family
have an electric bug zapper in the
backyard at point never Kippy um okay
have you ever had a KFC bowl no I don't
know what that is okay that's good [ __ ]
it's like basic layers of like it starts
off I don't think they make it anymore
but it starts off with like mashed
potatoes gravy cheese corn chicken
cheesy and I think okay no just like a
whole mess of whatever they got back in
a [ __ ] bowl and they give it this
sounds pretty good to me
yeah we you know we an FK FC once in a
while maybe like twice a year my dad
would splurge and we go to Kentucky
Fried Chicken cuz that was the
top-of-the-line stuff yeah so two like
twice a year you bring the family to air
or you bring up back home what we did it
mmm-hmm what was the last time you ate
fast food in your car you just sat there
and ate it oh yeah I took my kid to
White Castle hey that's a good dad right
there yeah we watched uh I want two more
oh yeah go to White House and it was
blown right by our dinners one right by
our house so he went to the drive-thru
it was open that we sat in the park I
hate it ah a [ __ ] vest man that's the
absolute best have you ever been to
Cancun yes for what was it for like
Thomas goes there
okay they were doing comedy shows just
booked a shady book or a book the
everyone forever shares the shady
butcher because you're gonna can't cone
it they will get like $300 for the week
on my count which one shows like six
days that are a week okay we get there
there's only one hotel room for three
comedians
because withstanding the resort in the
comedy clubs in the resort the first
night all three of us slept in the same
bed Jesus Christ and we Co calling a guy
we're trying to get in contact with him
from Cancun you know and then we went to
get a second room so we had to room but
yet was shady but it was great Cancun
was great
who are those comedians do we know them
and they still they're still around uh
no one was uh this guy Danny Vermont
he's a writer for Bill Maher show he's
been out in LA for a long time okay and
I can't remember the other guy but it
was it was sketchy and then we went to a
strip club we told the taxi bring it and
he took us like 20 miles outside of
Cancun
oh we're and every foot every every
minute you go you're getting more and
more nervous I'm like where the [ __ ] are
you taking me
if you ever seen you ever see from dusk
till dawn when they go to at strip clubs
up popped up in the middle of nowhere
Mexican I felt like we went in like five
minutes like we're gonna get killed and
we lucky to camp was still there he took
us back have you ever gone to any of the
resorts like sandals or hedonism or
anything like that
no okay what about a cruise you a cruise
guy I went out one grows when an
ex-girlfriend I hated it I don't seem
like a cruise guy is there is like a
heavy-metal cruise it's called Monsters
of Rock cruise every year we have a
bunch of different bands sound like
bands from the 80s and I go on every to
the last four years well a host I'll
introduce the band's I do a comedy show
so I do that
so yeah that's working no yeah but yeah
I'm gonna go if I wasn't getting paid
yeah have you ever gambled at an Indian
casino yeah I'm not a big gambler but
I've gambled a little yeah and you
casino yeah yeah have you ever been have
you ever hung out at an OTB
yeah I had a friend that was a big
gambler and he would uh he would go
there so I'd be in them like this is
pathetic sad scene it was in really good
shape uh so you're the only guy with six
pack abs in a no TV know that ever it's
a bad line up every time you go in there
and all the [ __ ] tickets on the
ground and [ __ ]
that's when you know you got a gamble
bro you're not even going to the track
I'll go to the track and make a day out
of it you see the horses
yeah that doesn't like BYOB that's an
event but if you're at the [ __ ] OTB
in Queens or like Newark or something
you really [ __ ] up there's the same
time I was bringing him to one of my
gigs and we had a listen it were like a
flyer exhibition game and on the radio
on an AM static radio because he had the
under in the front what's the under on a
hockey game was maybe one and a half or
two whatever was and I'm like you got to
be kidding me I can't listen this guy's
not come on they got a score I need one
more an exhibition game to the regular
season you bet on the Pro Bowl like a
[ __ ] camera commercial don't like this
is when you see your rock bottom oh man
I think that's [ __ ] so funny I think I
only got one more left here
have you ever requested to sit in a
smoking section I don't think so okay
maybe you know probably because if I
went the restaurant and it was only
tables in the smoking section oh my god
put me over there so yeah I would say
yeah that was we I mean I lived in the
smoking section all through the night I
I thought you were a [ __ ] if you didn't
my dad we would just go any like smoking
table for for smoking we were just
hanging out and [ __ ] people were just
baking it out with Newports the whole
time yeah because I was you know before
I did comedy I was a DJ in a rock club
and then the comedy club so I was always
in smoke and I am oh my god I didn't
like it but I was like whatever the
smoke I'll just deal with it so in a
restaurant no matter if [ __ ] that was an
allocation now if I feel so much smoke
around me it freaks me out I know it's
weird yeah that was an occupational
hazard for a comedian was the smoke I
mean you're a viewer in Club seven
nights a week they were just smoking in
there it was like you couldn't see like
a foot off the stage cuz of a smoke like
you do two shows on a Saturday I
remember in st. Louis the club there
[ __ ] just everybody smoked and it
looked like there was a fog machine
you couldn't do crowd work I just got
two more questions for you what I want
to know have you ever been or involved
in a monster truck show no never no I
mean I'm white trash but not that I
think your car Todd did so far man your
answers are pretty good yeah you're all
class just one last question would be is
the big thing on are you garbage is
growing up would you get milk with
dinner
did you drink milk with dinner jim
Florentine I would say no because what
would go with milk thank you nothing no
dinner goes with milk everything goes
with milk now because like if we had
cereal obviously in the morning we're a
big cereal family so that was the milk
and then maybe if you had cookies later
you would have milk with it yeah never a
dinner I mean because we knew that pizza
pasta
hambert or so the fun there's lunatics
Jim there's lunatics out there that
would sit down with a bowl of pasta and
a big glass of [ __ ] 2% and jam right
here
nope with what-what-what dinner would
you have milk Wes we'd have milk I would
as kids we got milk with every single
meal doesn't matter if it was pizza
pasta meatloaf was a big one he can't
hamburgers yeah I love all that stuff
with milk I love this it's gross did you
when you got older do you realize that
milk wasn't on the menu
my exact argument thank you well you
know it was that whole theory with the
parents is that you drink milk your
balls get bigger yeah that whole thing
yeah I was good marketing method [ __ ] if
my big milk I'll tell you that now it's
wide oh you get a lot of calcium your
bones in the draw I think they could
grow on their own yeah everybody else
seems to be doing all right without me
without the milk ah man no milk with
dinner I gotta tell you jim Florentine
you're all classic mine's a classy guy
that's a guy might be the first like
really really true all class
about everything I didn't really hear
anything other than things that like you
know the times dictated you know so he
set off some fireworks at a concert I
told you to I had my friend my friend
drag a couple miles like 12 years ago so
it wasn't like when I was like I can't
say I was 12 when I did it yeah was that
yeah we were talking about the seventies
I thought that is that like Molly
Hatchet or something no and tomorrow but
I went to a show I do it all again
oh my god I'm actually mad that I'm not
that I know you're I think I think your
your behaviors garbage I think your
upbringing was yeah your behavior you've
got some question will behavior for
shorts but I think your upbringing was
and your your life now is yeah it's all
class all class you got the finished
basement you know [ __ ] you're
shopping at a Wegmans I mean there's
some animals out there that are like
[ __ ] you know yeah organic spray on
deodorant I don't even know where you
get that that's rich guys [ __ ] it's not
that expensive you get away boys but no
but I still pit out like if I wear
regular do you know you don't want to be
on stage like that before he became a
comedy I'd be at pit stains that's what
everybody's gonna be focused or not like
what the hell's wrong with this guy
they'd be trashing you now oh my god oh
I dunno it works for me oh my god if I
got to pay an extra dollar but it's not
that you know yeah same t-shirt the next
day you're going to become actually we
all wish we had the extra dollar for the
organic deodorant in the finished
basement and the doodle Monster Energy
that's trashy but [ __ ] clean living
awesome man I had like they they
endorsed me for like a year or whatever
so I just saw it in my podcast by
Monster Energy and they sent me a
catalog do you want anything I go I'll
take the refrigerator like okay see
that's clean living it would be trashy
if you bought it if you see like 1,200
on a monster fridge now don't use that
as the main fridge upstairs in the
kitchen yeah that would be yet how'd you
get I do have a Jagermeister machine in
my face
that's that see you've achieved that
what every garbage person once you've
achieved it if you were to if you were
to talk to some like you know some bum
in Central Jersey be like hey one day
you'll have a [ __ ] a finished
basement with the basketballs thing a
monster energy a Jagermeister machine is
everyone explode you know anything I
guess if I put it on the kitchen take in
the kitchen a Jagermeister machines yeah
if it's in the bedroom then questionable
you know oh my god so fun so I'm
sticking with my original assessment jim
Florentine all class Skippy I love Jim
thank you so much Vance has been awesome
is there anything you want the folks out
there to know that we didn't mention my
podcast every Monday and Thursday on
barstool sports where we get podcasts
it's called everybody's lawful to
podcast awake afraid very nice
buddy honestly thank you so much for
coming on we really appreciate it
everything you got
yep ah yeah it was good yeah guys just
make sure you rate review subscribe on
iTunes and also full video is available
on youtube so you can subscribe there as
well we appreciate all the support so
far yeah we love you guys and we'll see
you next week for another exciting
edition of are you garbage one more time
mr. jim Florentine thank you so much sir
we appreciate it thanks man see you
about it